Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Ciao.
Agnese e Simone mi perdoneranno
se riassumerò le loro
bellissime, bellissime parole
in un paio di espressioni.
Agnese va in bicicletta;
Simone mangia poca carne;
Agnese e Simone cambiano
il mondo tutti i giorni:
eppure, non se ne rendono conto.
Io sono Sofia, ho 23 anni
e parlo di clima, crisi climatica:
divertentissimo!
So che per stare su questo palco
c'è bisogno di mandare un messaggio.
E quindi ho pensato: io ve lo dico,
voi lo assimilate un attimo,
così poi, dopo, andiamo avanti con calma.
Quattro chiacchiere in compagnia.
Il messaggio è:
non sottovalutate il potere che avete
di cambiare il mondo.
Non mi importa quanto pensiate
che i problemi dell'universo
siano troppo grandi per voi.
Non mi importa quanto pensiate che voi
siate troppo piccoli per risolverli.
No.
Ogni giorno cambiate il mondo.
Ogni scelta che fate,
ogni decisione che prendete,
influenzano la società di oggi,
cambiandola o mantenendola.
E se trasferiamo questo concetto
alla sfera climatica,
ogni azione che facciamo,
ogni decisione che prendiamo,
influenza il clima,
in positivo o in negativo.
Il clima che viviamo oggi!
Attenzione, però, a non cadere
nella colpevolizzazione dell'individuo.
La crisi climatica non è colpa nostra.
No.
A meno che non ci sia
il proprietario, o la proprietaria,
di un'azienda del fossile in sala,
allora possiamo star tranquilli:
nessuno di noi è colpevole
del collasso ecosistemico.
Detta così, aiuto,
sembra veramente allarmista.
Eppure è così.
Ci sono vari studi che mostrano
che ci sono 100 aziende al mondo -
che sono aziende dei combustibili fossili,
quindi gas, carbone e petrolio -
che dall'88 fino ad oggi
hanno prodotto il 71%
delle emissioni globali industriali.
Capite, quindi: 100
producono il 71 percento.
Tutti noi produciamo una piccola,
piccola parte del resto.
Ora, come cercare
di colmare questo divario?
Noi possiamo - le aziende del fossile
sono la causa della crisi climatica:
noi possiamo per caso essere la soluzione?
Sì, sì, più o meno.
So che magari qualcuno
si è posto la domanda:
ma io cosa posso fare per il clima?
Ebbene, io studio anche questo.
Le aziende del fossile
hanno in comune alcune cose, che sono:
devastazione ambientale;
sfruttamento e mancanza di rispetto
delle persone e delle zone, dell'ambiente
in cui si svolgono le loro attività;
e infine, l'accumulo
insostenibile di capitale.
Noi, davanti a questo, cosa possiamo fare?
Come dicevo, lo studio:
e lo studio a Copenaghen, in Danimarca.
Lassù dove c'è veramente poca luce,
veramente veramente veramente freddo.
E diciamo che vado avanti -
la mia vita si scandisce
tra pane nero e grafici.
C'è un grafico per tutto: per tutto!
Volete sapere qual era il clima
65 milioni di anni fa?
Boom: c'è un grafico!
Volete sapere qual è la relazione
fra aumento della temperatura globale
e concentrazione in atmosfera
di anidride carbonica?
C'è un grafico anche per quello!
Ce lo chiediamo
probabilmente tutti i giorni,
quando ci alziamo la mattina:
ma chissà qual è la relazione
fra temperatura e CO2?
E quindi, ho pensato:
facciamo che faccio un grafico
anche per i miei interessi.
Indubbiamente mi piace molto lamentarmi,
e mi piace molto lamentarmi
del buio che c'è in Danimarca.
Una cosa come 20 ore
al giorno: se va male, 24.
Un'altra cosa che amo fare
è l'attivismo per il clima.
Salvare il mondo, lotta climatica,
giustizia sociale: quelle cose lì.
E un'altra cosa che mi piace fare,
che so che porta un contributo
enorme all'umanità,
è cercare e trovare le foto di gattini
più belle su Internet.
(Risate)
E seppure questa cosa
mi rechi una gioia infinita -
bellissimo, bellissimo -
quello che faccio nella vita,
e diciamo passo il più tempo a fare,
è parlare di crisi climatica.
Già.
Parlo di crisi climatica sui social,
agli eventi, alle conferenze;
ma soprattutto su Instagram e Tik Tok.
Un'esperta che parla di crisi climatica
su Tik Tok: molto autorevole, devo dire.
Eppure ne parlo, e ne parlo anche tanto!
E la cosa curiosa è che io
i social li detesto,
li odio profondamente con tutto il cuore
perché ti ossessionano,
ti sfiniscono, ti mettono ansia.
L'ansia di dover creare
un contenuto di qualità
su una piattaforma
che non dà valore al contenuto.
Però lo faccio, lo faccio
perché ce n'è bisogno,
perché non possiamo continuare a sentire
che l'alluvione nelle Marche
è stata causata dalle forti piogge.
No, è crisi climatica!
Non possiamo continuare a sentire
che parte dell'Europa
brucia per il gran caldo:
no, è crisi climatica!
Non possiamo continuare a sentire
"siccità, effetto caldo":
no, è crisi climatica!
C'è bisogno di parlare di crisi climatica.
E quindi questo è quello
che faccio, in 60 secondi.
In 60 secondi parlo delle sfumature
della crisi climatica,
tutto ciò che spesso
non prendiamo in considerazione.
Questa mancanza -
Quando non prendiamo in considerazione
queste piccole cose, pensiamo che:
la crisi climatica non ci riguarda;
non ci toccherà;
è qualcosa che non si può risolvere,
perché alla fine
è il naturale corso delle cose:
sarà quel che sarà.
Sbagliato, più o meno su tutto, su tutto.
La crisi climatica non ci toccherà?
Cede il ghiacciaio,
strage di turisti sulla Marmolada.
Effetto caldo, dicono;
è crisi climatica, dice la scienza.
Non possiamo farci niente?
La tutela dell'ambiente
entra in Costituzione.
Curioso: 468 voti a favore,
uno contrario e sei astenuti.
Sarà quel che sarà?
La pagina è bianca.
Il futuro non è scritto.
Il futuro non è scritto: e noi, forse,
se ci guardiamo da qualche parte in tasca,
in borsa, nelle bellissime
borsine che vi han dato,
forse addirittura già in mano,
abbiamo una penna
con cui possiamo scriverlo.
Perché la crisi climatica è risolvibile:
noi possiamo risolverla, basta agire.
Una parola così piccola
eppure così potente: agire!
Chi è che agisce?
Agnese e Simone, tutti i giorni
o quando possono.
Sui social, sapete,
mi seguono circa 70.000 persone:
un discreto numero, di cui sono
estremamente grata e riconoscente.
E sono 70.000 persone
come Agnese e Simone,
o potenzialmente come Agnese e Simone,
che tutti i giorni
cercano e cambiano il mondo.
Agnese cambia il mondo tutti i giorni,
andando in bicicletta
e non rendendosene conto.
Fa parte di quelle migliaia e migliaia
e migliaia di persone che vanno in bici.
E di conseguenza chiedono, indirettamente
o direttamente a governi,
amministrazioni locali, chiunque,
di fare più ciclabili,
di dare più spazio alle persone,
e meno spazio alle macchine:
più spazi verdi, più spazi liberi,
più aria pulita.
E sono tutte cose che man mano arrivano,
chiedendo direttamente o indirettamente.
Il circolo virtuoso
potrebbe andare avanti quasi all'infinito.
C'è uno studio molto interessante
che ci dice che se noi tutti, chi può,
andassimo in bicicletta
dimezzeremmo la nostra carbon footprint,
praticamente la nostra
impronta di carbonio.
Quello che noi emettiamo ogni giorno,
ogni anno nella nostra vita,
in termini di emissioni.
Avete presente quel 71% delle 100 aziende?
Era la loro impronta di carbonio.
La nostra è infinitesima,
rispetto alla loro:
eppure noi, andando in bicicletta,
facendo un piccolissimo gesto,
potremmo dimezzarla.
Un altro studio ci dice
che se sostituissimo un tragitto
di due chilometri e mezzo in bicicletta,
un tragitto che solitamente
facciamo in macchina,
riusciremmo a risparmiare in un anno
700.000.000 di tonnellate
di anidride carbonica.
Che numero è?
È la quantità di anidride carbonica
che viene emessa da Italia
e Francia messe insieme:
la prima volta che Italia e Francia
sono effettivamente messe insieme.
Un'azione così piccola, così piccola,
ha un impatto enorme in un anno.
Ma c'è chi non può andare in bicicletta:
quindi, vediamo come cambiare
il mondo in meglio
anche non andando in bicicletta.
Ci sono veramente tante, tante, tante,
tante, tante azioni che si possono fare.
Vi potrei dire:
seguire una dieta vegetale;
muoversi in bicicletta; efficientare casa;
informarsi quotidianamente;
volare veramente pochissimo.
Però ce ne sono anche alcune
che sono particolarmente interessanti
e spesso sottovalutate,
o almeno certe volte non se ne parla.
Sapevate, ad esempio,
che forse la vostra banca
investe sulla crisi climatica?
Ma in che senso?
Nel senso che dovremmo iniziare
a investire bene.
C'è questa relazione che ci dice
che ci sono delle banche al mondo
che sono estremamente collegate
all'industria dei combustibili fossili.
Qua dentro c'è tutta la lista.
Ce ne sono anche due italiane.
"Banking on climate chaos":
fatturare sul caos climatico.
Un'altra azione che è fondamentale
è appellarsi ai governi,
chiedere ai governi
di fare la transizione.
La transizione vuol dire
decarbonizzare totalmente il sistema -
più ciclabili, più energia pulita,
più infrastrutture, più trasporti -
e trattare la crisi climatica
come una vera crisi.
Ci sono infiniti modi, anche,
di chiedere cose ai governi:
una di queste è votare bene.
Votare governi, persone,
che vogliono trattare la crisi climatica
come una vera crisi,
che siano disposti ad agire per il clima
e non necessariamente per il capitale.
Un altro modo per chiedere ai governi cose
è scendere in piazza.
Scendere in piazza con Agnese,
scendere in piazza con Simone,
scendere in piazza con i migliaia,
migliaia, migliaia,
milioni di ragazzi e ragazze e persone
che sono scese in piazza
negli scorsi tre anni
e che hanno cambiato il mondo.
Quella tutela dell'ambiente
è entrata in Costituzione:
per quale motivo è avvenuto? Per loro!
Per loro che chiedono, ogni giorno,
di tingere il loro futuro -
il nostro futuro! -
di verde e non di nero, come il carbone.
Sapete, per risolvere la crisi climatica
non abbiamo bisogno di perfezione.
Abbiamo, veramente,
solo bisogno di azione,
solo di azione.
La perfezione non esiste, no.
Quello che possiamo fare
è fare piccoli passi di consapevolezza,
che servano a noi e a chi ci sta attorno.
Diffidate di chi vi dice:
non sei perfetto, non sei perfetta.
Diffidate di chi vi dice
che la perfezione effettivamente esiste;
diffidate di chi vi fa sentire in colpa
di non fare abbastanza.
Ognuno di noi può fare qualcosa.
Ogni azione conta, seppur imperfetta.
Ogni azione.
Perché alla fine, uno più uno fa marea.
E le maree non possono essere fermate.
Noi possiamo essere marea.
Buona crisi climatica a tutti.
(Applausi)
Grazie.